the president used a rally last night to
justify his decision to kill an Iranian
general ahead of that missile attack on
US troops Salamone was actively planning
new attacks and he was looking very
seriously at our embassies and not just
the embassy in Baghdad but we stopped
him and we stopped him quickly and we
stopped him cold important to point out
that the president did not offer any
evidence and Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said later that he didn't know of
any targets for planned attacks Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill forests Nancy
good morning so if this comment was good
enough for a political rally was a good
enough for Congress what do they know
about the claim
well sources tell us Tony that lawmakers
were not told during a briefing by
administration officials earlier this
week about any imminent threats to US
embassies House Democrats voted
yesterday on a War Powers Resolution
aimed at staving off war with Iran amid
this growing controversy over exactly
what led the u.s. to assassinate
soleimani he was a bloodthirsty terror
and he's no longer a Terran he's dead in
Ohio President Trump defended the strike
before a roaring crowd the radical left
Democrats have expressed outrage over
the termination
of this horrible terrorist members will
record their votes it came after the
House voted to put limits on his ability
to use more force in Iran the current
resolution is adopted
the resolution pushed through by
Democrats would require the president to
get congressional approval first the
president should not be able to commit
the u.s. recklessly and flagrantly to
war three Republicans including one of
the president's staunchest supporters
Florida's Matt gates crossed party lines
I support the president killing
Soleimani was the right decision but
engaging in another forever war in the
middle east would be the wrong decision
but most House Republicans stood by him
the president has inherent article 2
Authority has commander-in-chief to
defend the United States in Ohio the
president railed against the other
congressional controversy impeachment I
did nothing wrong they don't even know
what the hell is going wrong in fact
it's so weak she doesn't want to put in
the articles it's so weak they're so
pathetic by she he means House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi who wants to wait to send
the impeachment articles to the Senate
until she gets more information about
the structure of the upcoming Senate
trial so are you willing to hold on to
the articles indefinite no I'm not
holding indefinitely I'll send them over
when I'm ready and that will probably be
soon Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell said that he is not going to
do what Pelosi wants and that any
decision about whether there will be
witnesses in this upcoming Senate trial
will take place after the trial gets
underway and he told his Republican
colleagues Tony that they should prepare
for the possibility that this trial will
get started as soon as early next week
I'll take it Nancy thanks Nancy Cordes
at on Capitol Hill
you